let's start out with with Nolan how did
you arrive at this formula of easy to
learn and difficult to master well
remember tari started out in the
coin-operated game business and so we
were sort of balanced between how do you
make a game that is satisfying
immediately upon dropping quarter in but
at the same time you had to get the
person to fail in three minutes so that
you get the next more money and and so
we decided that we had to make it
challenging enough that they wanted to
come back and get better and better and
better you know when you were starting
out you were not just starting your own
company as a young man but you were
essentially it was a birth of a medium
nobody thought that games were business
and so we always had no capital the
other part was the technology was really
lousy pong had a square ball not because
we thought that square balls were cool
it was because that's about as good as
we could do and and so we were
constantly fighting what we wanted to do
with what the technology would let us
hmm dong what for you are the essentials
of effective game design at first I want
my something that people can play
anytime anywhere I want to make
something that people can easy easily to
remember like I have a background of
city in a game and have a blue sky that
every of nitendo games Haas what was the
appeal of that generation of gains for
you the retro game is a more focus I
don't have to really learn how to play
mm-hmm I can learn by my own mistake so
you're talking about kind of a you know
really a frictionless kind of entry to
playing the game which I think was what
we all remember about those titles
growing up how did that influence kind
of the design of flappy bird
instead of adding more content in the
game I sue focus mode ha I could spend
more time on tuning the gameplay to make
it right let's talk what was until
recently one of the great urban legends
in gaming was that Atari had made so
many ET cartridges that they were buried
in a desert in New Mexico Nolan if you
knew those were there well it does i can
you just intolerable I had left three
years before so not on my wife can eyes
that were running Atari after me didn't
play games they were suits they don't
understand how critical the the
man-machine interfaces with the gameplay
and in those days a good cartridge took
at least six months to design they
thought that an ET game would be cool so
they did a licensing deal in late August
but the cartridge had to start shipping
in middle October and in six weeks to do
a full cartridge game it was impossible
I actually got an early copy it was
unplayable and so all of a sudden they
had the tsunami of returned cartridges
and so the best thing to do was to bury
him in the desert and then pour concrete
oh yeah what kind of games do you see
coming out on these these new forms of
hardware I think VR has always been this
promise of the holodeck for the Trekkies
hair out there and and that you're there
and I can tell you that the technology
is sufficient now that you can actually
be in VR and not throw up motion
sickness was always a big problem I mean
VR has been around on some levels for 20
years but the motion sickness issue is
you you have a hard time making a
business when you make people sick I
you know all the games i think is a dog
came adult adult game yeah but when you
say that what do you mean because here
augusta dog came as a different yeah
because i was in Tokyo before this trip
to write you are going to see a lot of
talking yeah yeah well anyway we're out
of time but thank you